oh
jeez man you're really chomping at the
bit aren't you it's so hard yeah it's
there's there's so much out there right
now to talk about and we just can't wait
did you just say chomping yeah jumping
at the bit no no it's it's champing Tom
it's an equestrian term Gerald it's
champing so Josh okay fine whatever see
this is what I'm talking about this
would be good this would be good stuff
for is it by the way is it is it March
20th March you can't like you can't
really talk too much about that but uh
but do by the way do you see that uh the
new CEO for for YouTube Neil Mohan do
you see that guy coming have you heard
it it's Mohan
it's actually is that it's Neil Mohan
yeah I mean the guy who
that's literally the guy who was
involved with removing 50 of our videos
after the Vox adpocalypse it's Mohan oh
oh
um whatever you say you know maybe uh
does this mean you want to maybe take
down the YouTube plaque that's hanging
in the bathroom
is that
we still have the YouTube pluck hanging
in the bathroom
God
[Music]
foreign
mother Brothers
mothers real
[Music]
foreign